con el último boletín de yabal 99 punto
25 por ciento escrutado pero gana por
711 mil 760 votos la diferencia igual no
es mucho creo que no habíamos tenido una
diferencia tan es tan corta entre los
dos candidatos y eso también es algo que
pero tiene que recordar durante su
gobierno petro llega políticamente
endeudado él hizo demasiadas alianzas
unas con personas de reputación
cuestionable y va a tener que devolver
esos favores durante su gobierno y esto
es algo que muchos de los electores no
se les olvida y les preocupa muchísimo
cómo va a responder con estos favores
políticos mientras que por el otro lado
rodolfo no tenía ninguna de estas
alianzas la situación de petros
muchísimo más comprometedora porque él
sabía que ésta era su oportunidad de oro
y efectivamente logró llegar ya es el
presidente de colombia pero vamos a ver
cómo responde a estos compromisos
previamente adquiridos como realmente se
va a comportar y cómo va a ser su
gobernabilidad va a ser importante
también entender cómo van a funcionar
los organismos de control en este
momento la contraloría la procuraduría y
la fiscalía son digamos
ejercidas por
personas mucho más cercanas a la derecha
de hecho muy cercanos a duke es una de
las grandes críticas que tiene duch en
este punto dentro de su gobierno y vamos
a ver cómo se comporta este este
mecanismo y estos frenos y contrapesos
la corte constitucional de sus nueve
magistrados seis van a tener que ser
reemplazados en los próximos cuatro años
y el presidente nos olvidemos que juega
un rol muy importante en presentar uno
de los tres nombres que se presentan con
la terna de cada uno de estos
magistrados entonces alguna manera vamos
a poner a prueba nuestro sistema de
frenos y contrapesos nuestra
institucionalidad esperemos que la
democracia digamos muestre sus bondades
y realmente logremos tener un gobierno
en donde si bien colombia es bastante
presidencialista tengamos esos frenos y
esos contrapesos creo que el rol del
congreso va a ser fundamental y me causa
curiosidad saber si rodolfo hernández
aceptará o no su crimen en el granado
porque como la ley de oposición lo
preveía digamos sólo lo predispone a
rodolfo debería ocupar un puesto en el
senado pero recordemos que no hay más
senadores contra la corrupción de su
partido político él sería el único en el
senado acompañado sólo por tres
representantes a la cámara a las dos que
ya tienen curul última la vicepresidente
entonces de esta manera tenemos un
escenario muy interesante no creo que
rodolfo hernández vaya a jugar un rol
muy importante en la forma en que se
presente y gamos la oposición política
no creo que vaya a ser quien lidere la
oposición política creo que lo retomarán
más los partidos de derecha cambio
radical el centro democrático el partido
de la 'u' creo que ahí se va a buscar un
poco más esa importancia de la de la
oposición dentro del congreso y que con
la ley de bancadas tendrán que presentar
su posición oficial
antes de posicionarse en el nuevo
congreso entonces sabremos un poco mejor
cómo se van a dar digamos estos frenos y
contrapesos institucionales económica